CBS News it was sitcom that's Bob Hart's
Abba Shola explores immigrant life in
America this show examines a
relationship between Bob a Detroit
compression sock salesman yep that's a
job and a viola
she's a Nigerian nurse they first meet
in the hospital when Alba Shola is
assigned as Bob's nurse after he suffers
a heart attack is my family still around
yes would you like me to get them oh god
no tell them I died difficult family
yeah
that is not your business if you like I
can't tell your family are sleeping and
to come back in the morning Oh that'd be
great thanks Abby
I'll be sorry Abby Shola sorry you can
call me Bob good night see Bob Rick Bob
the show stars Billy Gardell and flock a
well know what for you Billy
so welcome you to thank you for having
her I think this is gonna be fun to
watch the two of you develop together
but what struck me is I've never seen a
show like this on TV with the Nigerian
culture and the American culture it's
it's it's a it's a sweet show and it's a
show about a moment in both people's
lives where you find something in the
other that you don't you didn't realize
was there and for Bob who has his heart
attack he wakes up and sees this you
know when you have a moment like that
close to death the people you wake up
around or who care for you it imprints
on you so and and he finds something's
very striking and special about her and
he decides in that moment you know what
I'm gonna see if I can just get her to
give me a chance even though we're very
different but she never seemed to want
to give you a chance you know what it
seemed to give him a chance
well it might appear that way because
she has total vision in a way she's come
to this country and her goal is to
create a better life for herself and her
son specifically sent her suntan Ivy
League school
to become a doctor yes and that's been
her mission and that's all she's been
focused on so this comes as a surprise
to her so it takes a while for her to
notice huh do you realize what's going
on do you remember what jump to ask you
when you first read the script it just
seemed like it was written for me she
was my mom she was my eyes a lot of my
auntie's I grew up with back home in
Nigeria it was it's just a seamless you
came to this country in 2001 yes on your
18th birthday my 18th birthday
so does this does this show reflect your
experience yeah I guess it does it's I
guess it is similar and that way it
feels genuine to you is what I'm saying
genuine very authentic it's extremely
authentic actually and for you what
stuck out for you Billy because I'm
thinking is it are we gonna focus on the
race the difference in the race between
the two characters I think it's for me I
think it's it's a man who he's he's
divorced and he's stressed out about his
business and I think your priorities
shift when you go through something like
a heart attack and you go you know what
I should be taking a risk on things that
I believe are gonna make me a better
person make me feel better and what
struck me about the writing and what
Chuck Lorre does better than anyone is
there's heart involved yeah this is a
show more about anything else that
proves love pops up everywhere man but
but it just it's great that it's gonna
be a chance for both cultures I think to
learn about the other which i think is
exciting yes and I think I think I hope
we're going to explore a lot of
different foods a lot of Nigerian
parties possibly Nigerians like to party
oh my god we have a saying it's just
were denied in your bottom fudgie yeah
that's like a general term for like
having fun yeah yeah we're on limited do
you play guitar at those parties all the
success is taking her away from her
alternative dream of guitar like slash
slash is a huge inspiration
why was he your inspiration just his
melodies his riffs were just there's
just something hypnotic about it I was
first subconsciously introduced to his
stuff to his music through some pop
artists and then I started to explore
just him
Guns N'Roses I was like I need to do
this very humble - she played the bass
with David Bowie
did you really Wow for a couple of his
music videos yeah Wow and you sing too
I am just saying you see you sing first
episode will we hear more yes we do we
do and you might hear some of my music
on the show as well and you might hear
Matt what's your son Bob Seger so glad
you're back on TV you must be very
excited about this I'm humbled by I
really am and to be a part of a show
that I think spreads kindness yeah I'm
really I go home very proud every day
we've we've been finding moments that of
connection that I think are very
important right now and it's it's
important for us to remember to be able
to look each other and see each other as
brothers and sisters and mothers and
fathers and aunts and uncles that's what
we are
amen to that school yeah let the church
say Amen amen Billy and [ __ ]
congratulations thank you cheering for
you here on CBS Bob hearts out
mashaallah premieres Monday September
23rd at 8:30 7:30 central right here on
CBS